des chars israéliens le long de la
barrière de Gaza on attend une attaque
terrestre de la part d'Israël euh une
attaque d'Israël qu'on annonce imminante
mais quels sont les enjeux de cette
attaque terrestre possible et bien on va
en parler avec les cartes du service
infographie du Figaro et pour en parler
je suis avec Arthur bijota bonjour
Arthur merci d'être avec nous bonjour
bonjour Vincent bonjour à tous avec vous
on va revenir sur toutes ces cartes que
vous avez produit depuis euh de depuis
plus d'une semaine euh pour Le Figaro
pour mieux comprendre euh tous les
enjeux de ce conflit et je voulais
commencer par cette carte cette carte
c'est la carte des bombardements de Gaza
et des zones aussi qui sont grisé autour
de la bande de gaz est-ce que vous
voulez nous expliquer ce que c'est tout
ça oui depuis depuis samedi 7 octobre et
donc depuis les les attaques terroristes
du Hamas qui ont fait plus de 2300 morts
en Israël Israël riposte Israël bombarde
la bande de Gaza et comme vous le voyez
très très bien sur cette carte Israël
vise d'abord le nord de la bande de Gaza
et la principale ville de cette petite
petite enclave palestinienne cette
principale ville c'est Gaza City mais
Israël vise aussi des camps palestiniens
de du Nord du nord de la bande de Gaza
comme comme Jabalia par exemple vous
voyez plus au sud quelques traces de
bombardement Israël bombarde également
la ville de Rafa tout au tout au sud de
la bande de Gaza et d'autres
bombardements également assez importants
notamment pour viser des des têtes de
pont des des des pièces organisatrices
du Hamas des des C dirigeant concerne la
ville de de de canyunes qui est qui est
juste au-dessus de de Rafa et que voilà
vous pouvez voir ici sur cette carte la
zone grisée en revanche c'est toute une
zone militaire autour de la bande de
Gaza qui est fermée par l'armée
israélienne c'est-à-dire que si vous
êtes journaliste vous n'avez pas la
possibilité d'y aller par vous-même il
faut que vous soyez accompagné par par
par des soldats de de l'armée
israélienne et ce qui n'apparaît pas
également sur cette carte c'est une zone
plus petite qui s'insère dans cette zone
ise et qui concerne vraiment les
localités les plus les plus proches de
laamande de Gaza les localités
frontalières qui ont été évacuées et on
pense par exemple àderot là que que vous
voyez ici 20000 habitants environ qui a
été très fortement touché et qui a été
évacué ce dimanche par les autorité
israélienne effectivement c'était pour
notre première carte que vous pouvez
retrouver bien sûr sur le site du Figaro
on va revenir aussi sur sur Gaza sur la
bande de Gaza on se rappelle bien on est
entre l'Égypte et Israël euh on est sur
une zone une petite langue de terre avec
un accès à la mer assez restreint oui
c'est très petit he Gaza il faut savoir
que c'est à peu près 365 km² donc c'est
à peu près deux fois le département des
Hautes scènes pour que nos nos nos
auditeurs et nos et nos téléspectateurs
puissent puissent bien envisager tout
cela euh mais la bande de Gaza est sous
blocus israélien depuis très très
longtemps alors on dit généralement
qu'elle est sous blocus israélien depuis
2006 7 depuis la prise de contrôle du du
Hamas dans cette bande effectivement euh
depuis 2007 vous n'avez pas le droit si
vous êtes pêcheur à Gaza vous n'avez pas
le droit d'aller pêcher au-delà de la
petite zone qui qui qui qui est en bleu
ici tout ce qui est achuré c'est
interdit vous avez la comment dire la
possibilité de de vous faire interpeller
par la la marine israélienne également
tout autour de de de Gaza il y a une
clôture qui a été construite par Israël
à partir de 2007-2008 et qui a été
inauguré en 2021 c'est une clôture de 65
km tout autour hein vous vous voyez qui
est également souterraine qui est rempli
bardé de capteurs de caméras de
surveillance de de postees d'observation
et qui était censé prévenir toute
infiltration du Hamas et on peut dire
sans sans aucun doute que ça n'a pas
fonctionné puisque on retrouve au moins
une trentainee de brèches dans cette
clôture suite suite aux attaques de de
samedi dernier oui on on l'a beaucoup
dit depuis le début début 1 milliard
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est une
clôture qui a coûté très cher très
sécurisée et vous aussi parce qu'on voit
cette clôture en extérieur mais elle est
aussi sous terre pour éviter des des
éventuels tunnelsou souterraines pour
éviter les infiltrations qui passent qui
passent par les les tunnels du Hamas et
cette cette clôture euh faut savoir que
c'est pas uniquement un mur mais c'est
quasiment sur 1 km vous avez une une
véritable zone tampon en fait où les 100
derniers mètres sont accessible à aucun
habitant de la bande de Gaza les 300 m
avant encore sont uniquement accessibles
à pied et aux agriculteurs et toute la
bande d'un km est à accès limité donc
c'est une clôture mais également une
zone tampon d'un km à l'intérieur de la
bande de Gaza h effectivement euh on
peut on on peut le voir sur cette carte
euh cette cette C cette fameuse zone
tampon euh il y a des passages de cette
bordure pour pouvoir rentrer dans Gaza
il y en a qui existe il y en a qui
n'existe plus aussi il y en a qui existe
le seul et unique point de passage pour
les habitants de Gaza qui vont par
exemple travailler en Israël ou en
sisjordanie c'est le point de passage
des Res qui a été lui-même attaqué le 7
octobre ce point de passage des rest
concerne les personnes les biens les
marchandises et cetera il est ouvert
environ 6 jours sur 7 et c'est l'unique
point où en fait si vous êtes citoyen de
Gaza vous pouvez passer pour aller en
Israël ou en sjordanie vous avez un
autre checkpoint tout au sud qui est
celui de Kerem Chalom à Kerem Chalom
ouvert 5 jours sur 7 vous avez
uniquement les marchandises qui peuvent
passer et vous avez enfin un troisième
checkpoint juste à côté celui de Rafa
qui permet en revanche d'aller en Égypte
mais qui est également fermé à l'heure
actuelle c'est par là que transite la la
majorité de l'aide humanitaire euh en
temps normal et éventuellement s'il y a
un accord entre l'Égypte Israël et
cetera en ce en ce moment même c'est par
là que transit
l'aide humanitaire les les pour partir
d' s'ils obtiennent un accord pour
pouvoir partirs obtiennent un accord
pour pouvoir arriver en Égypte forcément
mais c'est voilà il y a ces trois points
de passage principaux il y en avait
d'autres qui qui ont fermé oui il y en
avait d'autres parce qu'il faut savoir
que Gaza entre 1967 et 2005 a été sous
occupation israélienne il y avait même
des colonies israélienne à l'intérieur
de la bande de Gaza donc il y avait un
véritable lien entre entre les les deux
territoires et il y avait des points de
passage comme à nal
un petit peu plus au nord que que vous
pouvez voir sur cette sur cette car deux
à côté là là qu'on voit ici voilà et à
et voilà à
Cami et à Soufa également donc vous
aviez des petits des petit des petits
points de passage mais qui après la
prise du pouvoir de Hamas en 2007 ont
été fermés au début de la décennie 2010
par les autorités israéliennes et vous
n'avez plus maintenant que trois
checkpoints un vers l'Égypte deux vers
Israël un pour les personnes un pour les
marchands 10 à peu près effectivement
parce que on peut aussi rappeler que la
bande de Gaza est un endroit qui est
très densément peuplé il y a vraiment
beaucoup de gens là on voit la une carte
de densité de population de de Gaza on
voit comment s'organise cette population
et on voit qu'effectivement c'est au
nord de la de de Gaza c'est d'ailleurs
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est les images
qu'on voit des des des immeubles qu'on
peut qu'on peut d'ailleurs montrer que
je pe pe que je que je peux vous montrer
ici voilà ces immeubles là c'est le nord
de Gaza c'est une zone extrêmement
urbaine effectivement quand quand vous
reviendrez sur la carte plus c'est
Orange plus il y a de monde et plus
c'est dense donc vous voyez évidemment
au nord de la bande de Gaza autour de
Gaza City cette très forte densité de
population vous avez environ 2,2 2,3
millions d'habitants sur 365 km² c'est
une densité impressionnante qui n'est
qui est équivalente à celle de grande
métropole et cetera donc faut imaginer
des bombardements dans dans dans ce dans
ce tissu ain très très dense de la bande
de la bande de Gaza et il faut également
savoir que au milieu de tout ça vous
avez des camps de réfugiés palestiniens
des gens qui ont été obligés de quitter
leur territoire au moment de la
fondation de l'État d'Israël en 1948 47
48 lors de et puis lors de la première
guerre israel-arabe le 48 49 c'est les
points bleus qu'on voit voilà c'est les
points bleus donc vous avez des camp
palestinien qui accueille environ 1,7
enfin 1,7 millions de personnes sont des
réfugiés palestiniens dans cette bande
de Gaza donc vous avez des camps qui
sont très densément peuplés au nord de
Gaza vous avez
Jabalia tout tout tout au nord qui est
un camp extrêmement dense c'est c'est
des camps qui sont encore sont très
vieux mais qui sont encore qui sont très
vieux qui sont géré par l'Agence des
nations- Unies en charge des réfugiés
palestiniens Luna et comme comme dans un
certain nombre de pays du du du de la
région au Liban vous avez également des
des camps palestiniens qui sont qui sont
gérés par cette agence des Nation Nation
Unies effectivement donc voilà on voit
ici la la population comment elle se
comment elle se divise finalement sur le
sur sur le sol israélien on peut montrer
aussi les infrastructures qu'il y a en
Israël puisque il y en a en Israël alors
on avait par exle une centrale
électrique qui ne marche plus
depuis depuis samedi depuis plus d'une
semaine c'est vrai Gaza ne peut pas
subvenir à ses propres besoin en en
électricité elle importe du du du
courant israélien et il y a quand même
des coupures il y a pas de de
l'électricité tout le temps mais Gaza
disposait d'une seule centrale
électrique qui fonctionnait je crois au
fuel au fuel lourd au diesel mais qui
est à l'arrêt depuis maintenant
quasiment une semaine depuis mercredi
après-midi faute de carburant donc ce
qui fait que la population de l'amande
de Gaza a encore moins d'électricité
surtout qu'Israël a a totalement coupé
son approvisionnement son
approvisionnement électrique sur cette
carte vous voyez
également le long de de la mer
Méditerranée deux petits pictogrammes
qui désignent les usines de dessalement
parce qu'il faut savoir que Gaza est
également pas d'eau potable n'a pas
d'eau a très peu d'eau potable et dépend
fortement d'Israël qui a coupé son
approvisionnement depuis depuis samedi
dernier donc les usines de dessalement
mais pour faire pour qu'ell fonctionn
ces unines de salalement faut de
l'électricité donc de fil en aiguille
vous voyez toute la crise humanitaire
qui se dessine à Gaza plus d'eau plus
d'électricité des des vivres qui qui qui
semble se se se diminuer et qui diminue
effectivement de de plus en plus donc
vous voyez la la crise humanitaire qui
se qui se dessine petit à petit à Gaza
oui on sur cette carte aussi les les
nombreux hôpitaux forcément on le disait
une population qui est très nombreuse
donc il y a de de de de très nombreux
hôpitaux très nombreux hôpitaux qui sont
quand même concentrés autour des villes
autour de Gaza City autour de canunes
autour de de Rafa et des hôpitaux qui
sont qui sont également on va le voir
après qui sont très nombreux dans la
zone qui qu'Israël a demandé d'évacuer
c'était je crois vendredi effectivement
il y a aussi ça qu'on voit sur la carte
un aéroport il y a un aéroport à Gaza ou
du moins il y en avait un puisquil a été
détruit depuis 2002 effectivement il a
été c'est l'aéroport international
yassar Arafat du nom du du fondateur de
de l'Organisation de Libération de la
Palestine l'aéroport était détruit par
des frappes israéliennes au tout début
des des années 2000 et il est donc
inutilisable et inutilisé effectivement
donc c pour cette cet aéroport que vous
voyez sur cette carte on peut montrer
cette carte maintenant c'est celle des
vous vous disiez aussi tout à l'heure
des des bâtiments de de de l'ONU qui
sont sur place de nombreux bâtiments
alors qu'est-ce qu'on comprend quand on
voit que sur cette carte au nord on a
ces trois bâtiments l'ONU qu'est-ce que
c'est que ces bâtiments de l'ONU
finalement c'est vrai il y a certains
bâtiments de l'ONU on on les a pas tous
mis évidemment sur C cette carte mais
l'ONU dispose de bâtiments ça peut être
des dispensaires ça peut être des écoles
dans lesquelles vont se réfugier la
population civile pour échapper au au
bombardement israélien parce qu'il la
population considère que l'ONU ne va pas
bombarder que Israël pardon ne va pas
bombarder des bâtiments appartenant aux
Nations Unies mais on ne peut enfin on
ne peut s'empêcher de penser et on a des
c'est compliqué de regrouper les
informations à Gaza où il y a très très
peu de gens journaliste et l'information
est compliquée à obtenir mais on peut
penser que la Hamas peut également
utiliser ses bâtiments de l'ONU comme
des comme comme des endroits pour pour
se cacher et éviter les les frappes
israéliennes qui qui qui sont massives
depuis depuis maintenant 10 jours et et
on voit effectivement sur cette carte
aussi les universités qui son qui sont
présentes oui on a décidé de mettre les
universités parce que Israël a frappé
l'université islamique de
Gaza je crois que c'était en milieu de
semaine dernière car elle considère
qu'elle for forme de ha cadre du Hamas
ce qui est pas ce qui est pas comment
dire ce qui ce qui ce qui est vrai par
exemple le cerveau des des attentats
contre contre Israël Mohamed Daif a
commencé je crois son cursus scolaire à
l'université islamique de Gaza qui a été
bombardé la semaine dernière
effectivement on peut voir maintenant c
c cette carte avec les les bases
militaires de de d'Israël qui qui était
déjà positionné tout autour de la bande
de Gaza oui des bases des bases
militaires israéliennes positionnées
tout autour dont certaines ont été
attaquées le samedi 7 octobre je pense à
la base de naal Z à Zikim et à REIM qui
sont les trois bases les les les plus
proches de laamand ne Gaza ils ont été
attaqués il y a eu des combat de
nombreux militaires israéliens sont sont
morts ont été tués euh des de nombreux
matériels également ont été ont été
volés par le Hamas mais Israël va
pouvoir s'appuyer sur ce sur ce réseau
de de base tout autour de la Gaza pour
préparer son offensive terrestre qui qui
qui s'annonce effectivement il annonce
qui une une pardon excusez-moi une une
offensive terrestre qu'on annonce
effectivement imminente depuis plusieurs
jours euh on on c'est pour ça qu'on vous
montre qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer
avant cette on a parlé d'une évacuation
possible pour les civils est-ce que
cette évacuation euh alors entre le Nord
et le Sud du du de la bande de Gaza
entre le Nord et le Sud parce que il y a
une limite géographique en fait voà
Israël a demandé à la population située
au nord de la petite rivière qui
traverse Gaza qui s'appelle wad Gaza en
arabe et donc Israël a demandé à toute
la population au nord de cette de cette
de ce fleuve hein puisqu'il jeà dans la
mer Méditerranée de quitter euh de
quitter de quitter de quitter cette zone
il faut savoir qu'il y a quand même deux
routes principales à Gaza la route qui
longe la bande côtière tout à l'ouest et
une autoroute centrale qui relie le
checkpoint des jusqu'au checkpoin de
Rafa donc à travers toute la bande oui
c'est c'est la ligne qu'on voit ici
voilà c'est la ligne que vous voyez ici
et qui qui descend jusqu'à l'Égypte mais
ces routes pour évacuer un million de
personnes en quelques jours semble ma
fois fort dérisoire effectivement c'est
c'est tout cas ce que ce ce qu'on t'
annonçait ce ce qu'on ce qu'on demandait
en tout cas Israël et c'est et et c'est
ce qui pose a priori problème aussi euh
je voulais vous montrer aussi cette
carte des des des des des des anciennes
attaques qu'il y avait eu voilà on voilà
on disait 1 1,1 million de Gazaoui à à à
évacuer et c'est c'est c'est ces
opérations terrestres de la part
d'Israël c'est pas quelque chose qui est
nouveau il y en a déjà eu par le passé
non il y en a déjà eu par par le passé
la plus importante je crois c'est
l'opération bordure protectrice
euh je crois que c'est en 2014 à l'été
2014 effectivement entre le 8 juillet et
le 26 26 2014 voà voilà entre à l'été
2014 l'opération bordure
protectrice qui avait qui avait où les
forces israéliennes étaient rentrées
dans Gaza faut savoir qu'à cette époque
le chef d'étatmajor israélien c'était
benig Gans qui est maintenant qui est
maintenant rentré au gouvernement
d'union nationale de Benyamin Netanyahou
il il y a quelques jours donc qui
connaît quand même assez bien le le
terrain militaire et et les opérations à
mener autour de Gaza mais oui oui Israël
est déjà rentré dans Gaza euh mais n'a
jamais su n'a jamais pu n'est jamais
arrivé à éradiquer complètement
l'emprise du Hamas hein l'opération
bordure protectrice 2014 vous voyez 9
ans après le Hamas dispose d'une
capacité de lancement de requête une
capacité à s'introduire et à pénétrer le
territoire israélien comme comme jamais
et et on dit aussi pour qu'il puisse
rentrer pour pour il y a il y a pas
beaucoup de chemins pour
non il y a très peu de chemins il y a
environ quatre routes euh qui qui qui
vont d'Israël vers Gaza comme on l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure il y a deux
checkpoints et autour vous avez une
barrière qui est censée être
infranchissable donc les les les options
sont sont peu nombreuses et Israël ne
pourra pas jouer sur les fites surprise
en attaquant d' un endroit absolument
improbable c'est ça d'une zone qui ne
qui ne serait pas qui ser pas probable
alors on va délaisser Gaza pendant un
petit instant pour pour parler euh d'un
d'un autre endroit qui est on va se
retrouver au nord maintenant d'Israël
avec une frontière avec le Liban où là
aussi euh des des des heures ont éclaté
depuis le le 7 octobre oui ce matin
comme c'est marqué en en très gros sur
la carte vous avez quatre terroristes
qui ont été qui ont été tués après une
tentative d'infiltration tout au nord
d'Israël et cétait au au Sud Liban hein
comme comme on dit euh l'action a été
revendiquée par le hzbola il y a eu
également ce matin même euh des des Miss
en titan qui ont été tiré autour de la
ville de metoula qui se situe tout au
nord d'Israël proche du plateau du Golan
alors on rappelle à nos téléspectateurs
le plateau du Golan c'est un un plateau
qui appartient à la Syrie mais qui a été
conquis par Israël lors de la guerre des
6 Jours en 1967 et qui a été annexé
depuis en 1981 donc là vous voyez la
zone la zone grisée puis vous avez
différentes zones ensuite qui sont des
zones démilitarisées sous contrôle de
l'ONU des zones revendiquées par le lib
en c'est une région déjà avec des
frontières assez floues avec des
frontières assez floues une région
montagneuse donc c'est c'est voilà c'est
et depuis le début la grande la grande
inquiétude d'Israël c'est ouverture d'un
second front vousz le Hamas Gaza au sud
et vous avez le hzbollah le parti chit
libanais qui multiplie les les
incursions les petites
oui les petites incursions à la
frontière par exemple ex ce matin des
agences de presse libanaises annonçaient
que un tiers des caméras de surveillance
à la frontière avaient été détruitite
par le hesbola donc vous avez des
petites actions comme ça du hzbola des
petites actions qui qui qui qui sont
quand même importantes on parle de
lancement de missile sur sur des sur des
villages sur des kibutes et cetera ce
n'est pas rien mais pour l'instant le
hzbola n'a pas n'a pas choisi
l'ofensiveofensive et l'option de de de
l'escalade c'est une escalade somme tout
encore assez limité mais c'est
effectivement une zone à surveiller
parce que Ben vous avez également des
camps palestiniens au Liban donc des des
des gens et des factions qui peuvent qui
peuvent accompagner le hzbola là les les
les deux carrés noirs présents sur la
carte c'est c'est également deux villes
où l'armée libanaise a démantelé des des
lanceurs de roquettes hier donc vous
voyez que il y a quand même des des
choses de prête et que c'est c'est c'est
une zone voilà une zone très très très
explosive très contesté aussi en plus
très contestée et qui a déjà connu le
sud Liban une occupation israélienne
entre 1978 et 2000 donc vous avez
également le le poids du passé qui qui
peut qui peut jouer effectivement merci
beaucoup en tout casur Bota nous avoir
fait le point sur tous ces t tous ces
sujets je voudrais juste montrer à nos
internautes cet article qu'on pe
retrouver sur le site du Figaro
décryptage guerre Israël àamas le
terrain d'une possible offensive
terrestre décryptée grâce aux cartes
pour
don l des intéressant merci
beauoup une fois de plus restez avec
nous sur le site du Figaro et sur Figaro
live pour d'autres live et moi je vous
dis à
bientôt